[Musique]
je sais ce que vous vous dites vous êtes
venus pour écouter des sommités des
ingénieurs des chercheurs des grands
directeurs de service public et vous
vous retrouvez avoir payé votre place
pour le goûter
- paul 20 ans comme même la description
étudiant à l'école centrale celle à qui
mon approche du thème il va créer un
être humain
excusez moi que son ex petit espoir
lorsque nous sommes jeunes que nous
sommes le plus rêveurs n'est ce pas
lorsque nous tout est évident
d'expérience que celle ci est à même
d'être remplies par les rêves je ne sais
pas pour ce qui est à moi de prouver
comment ça je m'appelle book paul g
partant ça pour ça et là comme tout
jeune de mon âge je vais en cours je le
sport est parfois je regarde le jt
j'entendais paraître calais la jungle
je me suis renseigné que les matches je
rêvais c'était trois plans furtifs
prépare un camarade de france 2 entre
l'actuelle politique et la météo pour
croire que c'est déjà assez pour
éveiller la curiosité comme tous les
jeunes de mon âge je m'adonne avec
justement c'est à mme livni
on se racontait d'accord ce qu'on allait
faire est parti à guéret pour faire de
l'humanitaire
dans deux semaines le fer ça nous à
notre âge et voilà c'était déclic comme
quelques jeunes de mon âge
voilà donc embarqués pour l'animal iter
en france à calais pour qu'au lieu de
l'été j'avais donc envie de vous parler
vous parler cette semaine à la fois
magnifique et enrichissante mais aussi
teintée d'un parfum d'horaires et de
désespoir
c'est ce lieu la jungle
qui a fait naître tous les fantasmes
tous les clichés dont vous avez comme
tous les gens de vos âges sans doute
entendu parler et la journée que je
m'apprête à vous raconter est justement
un condensé de cette semaine ou tous mes
clichés et où je l'espère tous vos
clichés où étaient abritées dénoter
quand on arrive à calais il ya donc 9
heures et on ne peut pas s'approcher de
la jungle en voiture les croisements
entre bénévoles ça à ton juste ici wen
est moisi c'est à l'entrée dans une zone
industrielle
on doit donc il a à traverser cette zone
industrielle il fait froid il fait
porter et puis attendent toujours d'y
apprendre toujours comme le premier jour
car tu ne sais pas si la personne que tu
as vu hier à qui tu a serré la main sera
encore là le lendemain et si elle n'est
plus là tu ne seras pas pourquoi alors
tu change un peu les idées je discute
avec les bénévoles
en général ce sont des jeunes étudiants
du vieux et retraités
il ya aussi des instits et des mines et
les bénéficiaires du rsa quand même je
ne crois pas vous avoir dit qu'il y
avait dans la jungle c'est pas facile ça
bouge tout le temps il ya des afghans et
soudanais quelques éthiopiens et
quelques tchadien les syriens libyens ou
irakiens ont vu leur demande d'asile
plus rapidement accepté et sont plus
forcément là sont des jeunes des hommes
mais enfin à 18 ans il faut déjà deux
fois plus du coin un peu tout ce qu'ils
ont traversé il ya aussi quelques
familles et les gens plus âgés sont des
gens riches dans leur pays des gens
notable des diplômés car il faut de
l'argent pour payer les passeurs
cela change déjà un peu a priori ce sont
des artisans des médecins des
professeurs les commerçants et le défi
est là mais indiquent les intégrer tous
en tant que tel donc il est temps que
prenne ouvert avec tous ces gens qui
sont donc comme moi ici par hasard ce ne
sont pas des dents un kouchner décès des
parents bien sûr là par hasard
on arrive au pas
tout ici et on se demandait où là on
voit se répartir les tâches
ce matin je vais aller à l'école alors
le parce que oui il ya une école il ya
aussi des églises y aussi des mosquées
est aussi rare là c'est une vraie petite
ville alors il faut remonter jusqu'à
l'école est située dans la partie sud de
la jungle juste ici alors on va remonter
leurs commerçants parce que même ici il
ya une rue commerçante
on passe acheter des clopes c'est en
euros le ticket pour les fumeurs en fait
coca zéro keffieh chaussures qui peut
tout trouver d'ici là en fait il ya plus
de commerce que dans une ses visages en
bretagne alors il faut remonter à
l'école on passait par cette partie sud
qui a été démantelé au printemps en fait
entre landes la nature a vraiment repris
ses droits
parce que c'est ça la jungle side c'est
la menace sans cesse et toujours vie
démantèlement qui se rapproche
comment continuer quand tu ne sais pas
si l'endroit où tu vis experts encore
demain comment continuer quand il ne
sait pas s'ils ont rendu d'or sera
encore des coups de main l'aviez tueur
et si c'est ça la réalité de la journée
alors on passe entre un terrain de foot
on longe des visites au piano passe
quelques points d'eau pure à lima
l'école ils nous disaient qu'est ce qui
se passe à l'école
les bénévoles font apprendre le français
le français de tous les jours dans la
rue pour les papiers pourrait débarquer
dans nos stratégies
on va apprendre à compter l'alphabet à
lire à écrire on passe le portail à mai
et ça me do soudanaises sont au fond là
bas tables et chaises vides
c'est pour moi ce qui m'a marqué la
première fois c'est leur attention
j'ai déjà vu des types aussi de
déterminer aussi concentrée dans les
cours que j'avance les étudiants sont
studieux et eux ils voulaient tout après
tout un dur j'étais jusqu'à la dernière
goutte
je ne suis pas si toi toi ou toi on
l'écouté encore mais eux là bas c'est
des morts de faim
ils voulaient tout savoir pourquoi parce
qu'ils veulent une nouvelle situation
l'histoire en france par hasard aussi
ils cherchent un endroit de plaies ont
commencé notre vie ils veulent
s'intégrer au plus vite et le mieux
possible
tenez molex on a croisé à bordeaux après
une partie de foot en trois semaines il
connaissait déjà plus de conjugaison du
verbe avoir que moi j'appellerai de foot
oui je jouais au foot presque tous les
soirs en fait aujourd'hui à la jungle
c'est pas très loin d'une journée
d'étude en vente et tu te lèves tu vas
en cours durant le sétois
je vais acheter quelques bières je la
jouais au foot tu prends un peu tu vois
tes potes et puis tu vas te coucher
en fait ces gens sont purement et
simplement comme deux heures plus tard
une autre midi le cours se terminent
avec s'en va il doit appeler sa famille
au soudan du sud
il a sans doute acheté sa carte de
crédit de téléphoniques internationales
à mon mot qui tient les chapes juste
derrière le restaurant du lac il dope sa
famille qui réside dans cette ville dans
cette banlieue de de ville de sedan du
sud les qu'il a quitté pour fuir les
milices et autres exactions aux
dictatures sanguinaires
c'est à l'arrêter d'agen glossy sont des
gens qui sont séparés de leurs familles
qui ont tout quitté
dans l'espoir de trouver une autre vie
pour vivre pour trouver un autre avenir
et qu'il préférait bien sûr 0 chez eux
parce qu'ils avaient entendu j'ai pas
les restaurants et miniers 13 heures et
on doit chercher un restaurant en fait
et beaucoup assurément la jungle ardent
pour la plupart c'est à dire les avions
qui tiennent la plupart des commerçants
de cette rue qui donne aussi des
habitations à voir pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont arrivés en premier et ce à peine
attention justement les tensions entre
les ethnies d'arguments contre
d'affrontements parce que c'est ça aussi
la jungle c'est d'ailleurs la recherche
de la meilleure place toujours la
recherche de la meilleure phase on passe
on remonte donc jusqu'au jusqu'au
restaurant et
on passe devant le flou de troie qui
seraient plus les repas de la paix jobs
kitchen les réfugiés sont vraiment mis
en rang d'oignons comme ça à la queue
leu leu faut savoir que les étudiants
ont voté en culture rue des saules à
jacques cherche un restaurant donc on va
aller celui qui est juste un peu plus
loin là bas à 100 mètres au fond dario
le restaurateur et afghans il a bientôt
présenter te parler d'islam été
questionné sur la jungle et sur ce que
tu peux y voir lorsque tu peut en penser
il obtient les français en fait tu nous
vois nous qui aiment les des dons qu'il
n'est pas aigri vous êtes plus ou moins
tous bien il vous a bien
il ya donc une histoire lui aussi en
fait c'était restaurateurs aussi en
afghanistan ce restaurant a brûlé il ya
donc fui faut que les talibans il a fait
pour sauver sa peau il ne vient pas là
comme j'entends à droite ou à gauche
pour 20 du travail
il verra pour sauver sa peau bon alors
on se pose c'est être bientôt ceinturon
les assiettes de jean-luc légumes le
teich une 106 50 centimes on se pose sur
les nations lèvres de chaussures au
faciès
on se repose et puis donc entre la
presse et vos 14 heures on se retrouve
entre bénévoles avec une équipe
d'avignon va aller ramasser des déchets
en fait c'est l'activité principale dans
la jambe il faut toujours l'avait encore
et toujours plus parce que la célébrité
est un fléau pour l'hygiène et pour les
maladies alors on quitte le terrain ont
quitté un mouvement qui est plutôt là
pour entrer en territoire soudanais
juste ici vous voyez juste entre le
dortoir de 1500 places pour une longueur
d'asie et centre-sud télé qui est là
avec se sont fait c'est un centre aéré
désaffecté qui sert maintenant à l'aide
humanitaire
il y a dix mille repas peuvent être
discret par jour il ya aussi des ong
il y a aussi le mot 27 eur dans ce
dernier lieu n'est pas loin de rentrer
je ne suis pas une femme et femme donc
s'ils font chouchouter toute la journée
avec leurs enfants
je pense qu'elles se passent de très
beaux moments qu'il est des dates un peu
du quotidien
bon revenons à nos déchets ça 7,39 de
travail faty faut remplir le plus de
sacs poubelles possible c'est un jeu
presque
par contre on fait pas très sélectif les
bouteilles en verre les déchets
alimentaires et les rapports vont tous
dans le même sac
alors il est 16 heures deux heures plus
tard on va faire une pause ce qu on fait
toujours des pauses comme les com c'est
un groupe de soudanais qui stoppe sa
partie de cartes pour nous inviter à
apporter alors on les connaît ça donne
ça arrive tout le temps ce genre
d'invitation et il faut les accepter
c'est ça va si la rencontre le partage
de culture et leur premier vient d'être
en france c'est pareil ça commence
l'intégration celui qui pour l'audit est
juste là c'est un chercheur en physique
ils adorent end et ce n'est des schémas
sont les tables des équations
il connaissait une parlait souvent de
l'équation e mc2 je ne sais pas pourquoi
je comprenais pas très bien se donner et
il a une histoire mais aussi en fait il
a fui le soudan du sud vous rappelez
vous ai parlé de cette dictature
sanguinaire il ya des minutes
sa femme et sa fille se sont fait
assassiner par les mêmes milices sa
femme a fermé les et dans ses bras donc
c'est des gens qui fuient la guerre de
massacres dash et ne sont pas là pour le
plaisir
il m'a dit un jour et faisant que la
plus belle leçon que j'ai apprise de la
e ne peut être déprimé toute la journée
je ne peux pas rester renfrognée en coin
il faut toujours continuer à sourire à
chanter à avancer je crois que là qu'on
rêvait en inventer vous entendez la
force après tout ce qu'ils avaient vécu
après cette traversée
avant ces souris vous l'avez été voilà
ont continué à chanter
on essaie de partager nos chansons on
voit des traités et en repart pour les
déchets ça s'est un peu plus au travail
de corée français une voie d'eau traitée
dès 18 heures c'est la fin de la journée
enfin la fin de la journée on passe à la
plongée afghane en euros les 3 dan pour
les intéressés
et puis on va jouer au foot en fait on
joue au foot c'est juste derrière la
prairie à bail des terrains de foot
c'est facile à une équipe enlève son tee
shirt pop sa garde
et puis c'est parti il y avait deux
trois gars qui était vraiment fort qui
sait peut-être les futurs zidane platini
aurait donc eu plein à l'époque 19
heures on passe devant l'école paul fort
de la junte et la journée notre journée
à nous n'est pas terminée inventaire
nouvelle à grande synthe
c'est juste 20 minutes en voiture en
l'état car je n'ai pas encore parlé de
grande synthe cet accord de fusion à
kadhafi lecture est un vrai c'est un
camp de réfugiés
non au commissariat pour défier de l'onu
en fait c'est un camp avec beaucoup de
rooney comme celle ci les fanions des
shelters envoie avec une prise
électrique
les toilettes sont plus propres qu'à la
fac il ya sept tentes et on tu peux te
poser toute la journée pour quelques
gâteaux et discuter qui tu veux
alors ok c'est pas très dur mais c'est
déjà un exemple
voilà ce que damien carême c'est vrai
cela a fait avec un courage énorme et
une volonté et une bienveillance sans
limite
en fait c'est tout le contraire de cours
duquel il a fallu expliquer aux citoyens
travailler les associations les ong qui
financent et s'occupe du camp toutefois
un accueil décent est possible mais pas
dans ce top 25
alors c'est pas facile parce que pour
soi plutôt d'honneur que de sourires et
il ya pas beaucoup de gens qui
s'arrêtent fils en baisse nous y dépose
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'anglais qui
sont bénévoles qui sont bénévoles à
calais on arrive au cas à grande-synthe
il est 20 heures
on arrive donc en voilà pour une paire
cadres et oui de la méfiance quand je
sais cuisiner en fait de 20 heures à 23
heures de la venue pour faire mais nous
on est là enfermé à l'intérieur et on
l'avait découvert sur pied d'événements
pour les remettre et pour les nouveaux
arrivants alors on est enfermé et on
discute avec nos amis par la fenêtre
parce que c'est ça aussi un conte
réfugiés la nuit c'est opaque
on ne sait pas s'ils s'y passe il ya
deux jours il ya une fusillade alors il
ya trois semaines il ya une petite fille
qui était gelé
et quand je suis parti habite encore
pour sa survie c'est ça un camp de
réfugiés la journée on se barre ensemble
tous ensemble pour survivre mais la nuit
certains se battent les uns contre les
autres c'est une réalité pense qu'il
faut en parler il ya des mafias qui sont
mises en place dans le corps pour les
placer et celle ci décide de tout qui
habite roux qui travaillent ou comment
est on peut rien lui faire en fait
au final je crois que c'est la première
faute d'organisation secret quand vous
mettez un stade
on sort donc à 23 heures je croise une
pote ferrière ils nous proposent de
cigarettes
je pense aussi césar qui reste ainsi
qu'en ille xiii ou bénévoles que paulo
ce qu'a dû apprendre cette expression
aujourd'hui il parle aussi bien pensé
que nous ça fait de moi j'étais là donc
je suis fier
il a son sac à dos sa montée en cuir moi
je rentre fait marrer pierre et aurélien
lui il part pour essayer de passer en
angleterre
en fait chaque nuit il ya eu zéro et 30
personnes qui arrivent à passer de
l'autre côté
voilà ce que cette journée dans la jambe
on arrive en ce lieu qu'à des clichés
forcément tu as des clichés je pense que
ces gens ne sont pas comme toi ou plus
comme toi certains voient ces personnes
comme des sauvages comme des voleurs
comme une vague de personnes venues nous
enverrions au mieux comme de la main
d'oeuvre passe qualité que j'aimerais
que vous reteniez de ces mots vous
essayez de vous dire c'est que ces gens
sont la fois simples ou complexes
ils ont le même caractère que vos amis
avant de réussir cette traversée
terrible commencé à cause de fait
souvent horrible ils ont lu belle
journée que vous et moi ils ont eu la
même envie de réussir que vous et moi
toutes ces actions que je vous ai
présenté
on est des hommes est toujours à faire
survivre ces gens un temps et toutes nos
actions
donc maintenant faire sortir ces gens du
simple stade de la survie toutes nos
actions doivent les aider à faire partie
intégrante de notre société à
recommencer une vie normale ma victoire
sera bien un jour une personne dans
cette salle se mobilisent sur notre camp
comme celui-là comme celui de la
chapelle à paris
ma victoire sur un 15 jours une personne
qu'on sait que ça donne des cours de
français dans sa ville à des réfugiés
car oui c'est possible ma victoire sera
que quelqu'un ici donne quelques
vêtements world à remplir quelques
papiers
ma victoire sera que le bouche à oreille
qui m'a conduit par hasard à calais
continue pourquoi toujours et encore
plus de personnes et ce déclic pour que
cette personne s'intègre qu'il
recommence une autre vie certes une
fille qui leur convient et qui leur
plaît parce que c'est
l'intégration que j'ai vécu va apporter
au moins deux sources de bonheur c'est
celle que la vie continue
une communauté s'était construite avec
ses avantages et ses inconvénients d'une
ville s'était construit et se
déconstruit des liens s'étaient faits et
ce sont des faits les gens s'étaient
adaptés ou non même dans nos pires
cauchemars
la vie continue et comme c'est martin
luther king les ténèbres ne peuvent
combattre les ténèbres
seules les lumières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]